and it's gonna be one awkward weekend
Paul Rudd used to be an olive Judd
Apatow movie you think Judd Apatow was
like screw you Paul Rudd used to be an O
my movies no one leaves me I'm gonna go
toe to toe with your next movie I'm
gonna open the same weekend oh [ __ ] it's
a Marvel movie Oh
train wreck so train wreck stars Amy
Schumer directed by Judd Apatow and
written by Amy Schumer and pretty much
Amy Schumer in this movie plays Amy
Schumer how Amy Schumer jokes about
herself in her comedy she doesn't date
exclusively she likes going out on the
weekends getting drunk and banging dudes
then she meets Bill Hader who's a sports
doctor and they start dating it's like
uh maybe this can be exclusive maybe I
like him maybe my old life isn't the
life I want forever sounds kind of by
the numbers wrong calm yeah that doesn't
mean the execution always is I was
really impressed with this movie first
of all the fact that Amy Schumer wrote
it blows my mind so much you got skills
it's always awesome to see I like the
chemistry between her and Bill Hader and
I had some relevant moments like moments
when they're arguing you're like I know
couples that argue like this holy God
and that it kind of hit me as relevant
satire and I love seeing that in comedy
as any kind of movie really and this
movie had me laughing I would be
boldface lying to you if I said the
movie just didn't have me laughing and a
few quite a few saying I never belted
out laughter it was never the kind of
laughter that I'm going to remember but
there were some nice roads of chuckling
that happened throughout the movie what
really kept this movie from being the
comedy I'm going to remember forever is
the fact that it's more of a dramedy
there's a tough balancing comedy I get
that you can't have it just be all
comedy because at that point you have
slapstick you straight up have the Three
Stooges you want to make a relevant
comedy you got to throw some drama in
there some realistic [ __ ] some relatable
things for the folks at that point it's
a balance you got to balance the drama
with the comedy and on quite a few
occasions the drama was eclipsing the
comedy so at that point if I'm sitting
at home and I'm like I just want to
laugh I want to watch a comedy right now
it's probably not gonna be trainwreck
because I don't want to you know kind of
feel bad I got to be in the dramatic
mood for that and I'm not saying that's
a bad thing necessarily I'm just saying
you should know that right now people in
the comment section look new [ __ ] then
we're gonna watch movie be like oh
that's what he meant okay
he was right I'm not deleting my comment
and the movie really is a by-the-numbers
rom-com when you look at the premise the
executions a bit different that's where
the drama comes in but all in all most
movies like this have someone who loves
the single life does not date
exclusively and it starts dating someone
exclusively and they think well maybe I
like this whatever you think will happen
in there definitely happens in here but
in the end guys trainwreck was pretty
impressive
I liked Amy Schumer's writing it made me
actually appreciate her comedy more I
dare say she's funny because the movie
actually funny and true judd apatow
fashion the movie seems way longer than
it needs to be and you get out of the
movie and you're like that was less than
two hours I'm confused but all in all I
had a good time with this movie most of
all I love Bill Hader and Amy Schumer's
chemistry together I love that [ __ ] this
is the best Judd Apatow movie I've seen
in quite some time and I will say
trainwreck is a good time no alcohol
required alright guys so trainwreck have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more